here we got a guy Springfield wrestling
let's get into this Jim went out of uh
Springfield Illinois and Ted yeah but we
could have we're wrestlers close out
with some King kar stands what's up guys
Marc from Massachusetts last week a
place last place in the talent
competition this week I got a king
interesting for you guys what do you
guys think about scars that
standard-issue scar tissue of the scar
from brain surgery at a brain tumor
removed a couple years back Brendan and
I got that cauliflower from wrastlin had
it drained a couple times but just keeps
coming back so uh showing off your scars
King under stinging gang getting
buzz-buzz dude first of all thanks for
sending something in not getting the
victory and coming back hard with this
second hitter right yeah dude tattoos
are the Lord you know the Lord your
tattoo artist when you get tattoos
that's up to the big man upstairs when
you get scars you mean yeah that's true
loss the way to go there all of them are
original you have any scars my friend
got bit by a shark
we knew that close to somebody who's
been [ __ ] snagged on Grayson I mean I
know him well enough to call him and get
it on FaceTime any time so actually oh
you have no powers away actually so I
can't even do that yeah let me guess got
bit by the shark and then probably got
on some morphine for the pain
yeah then it led to pills yeah that's
exactly what happened to us that long
game great white yep
god I forgot yeah that's crazy you do
that man yeah you're like the drug
whisperer dude let me guess you know
some guys sitting there shooting up he's
just like to tell me everything you got
an a mild fender bender I swallowed a
bunch of coins and always yelling how to
get him taken out of my body through
there
yep and then went right through here and
then what else happened not much I got
that Earthworm Jim hit her hair knocked
the dude out and then they have to put
plates on my hand
did you really pound fracture why would
you what party
get him with uh I knocked my left hook
that is on the ground there like finish
it I'm like for sure I don't need to
[ __ ] no nonsense Keith was too late
to the game so I punched him and I at
the time is some low-level league in
Virginia like yeah we can't pay for that
really pay for it myself you to pay for
the guy not to pay for the surgery must
pay for any of it
meanwhile still wandering around North
West Johnny Curtis really happy yeah I
knew it was bad work too cuz it's a huge
scar my thumb's not great and I go how'd
it go he goes I did my best the doctor
yeah I did my best
right on you know get some weird guys
give me scars cat um just one on my
pinky that's it I cut myself trying to
cook a sweet potato and I shouldn't got
stitches but I just put a bandaid on it
for two weeks
Melanie skirts Pomeranian that makes
sense chin any scars yeah then what I
got a few but this is the biggest one Oh
what was that one from on your hand I
kind of fight with a Vietnamese gang
yeah people they're people huh my uncle
says sorry it's okay
it's been a long time they hit you over
the head with something you know those
Maglites mop shoes someone snuck in
during the fight and then smacked me
right in the head did it knock you out
he knocked out but I just I felt like I
just insulate was in a dream oh yeah did
it feel it felt warm right dude it was
like water hose of blood going down my
arm so that was warm and then I just
felt like I was like and it kind of
feels high yeah I felt felt like I was
in a dream good that's when someone sat
on my car so that sounds like what the
[ __ ] and then I realized oh [ __ ] he's a
gang member and his whole gang came out
with bats
also they had bats clubs and whose
by yourself my other friends everywhere
are you sure this sounds like an episode
of this sounds like this fast and
furious Tokyo do back in those days
though we were like Bad News Bears we
were racing our import cars yeah drivers
Nick in these cars I'd appendix taken
out middle school and one time I was
snowboarding just in the backyard of my
friends and the snowboard came up and
hit me in the head I'm not really
snowboarding but I'm just hanging out on
the board yeah it's just falling
basically but flight I used that
appendicitis car years later when I was
working at Sports Authority because I
wanted to go to a music festival and I
just kind of like reddened it up and I
put bandages on him and I just like dink
all in and I was like I had appendicitis
and they showed him the scar and it was
it looked fresh to move so sound set in
Minneapolis saw Mac Miller it was
awesome Wow really poor he died huh yeah
it was the is it like 2013 but best live
performer I've ever seen he's been our
shows too so that's hurts to hear that
[ __ ]
fentanyl got him huh fentanyl fentanyl
we got be shoppers Johnny Curtis
oh yeah I'll tell you what I break my
this is oh this is 12 years ago is it
really in watches in Fairfax Virginia
right next to Washington DC your
knockouts about to happen
yeah yep this is why I broke my hand and
I got Saabs
I got set up let me let me set up the
fight so I had one fight and then they
go hey do you want to fight out of town
I go sure you go we get this guy here's
some wrestling and I go okay cuz I was
in a wrestler so I'm I said I'm fine I
wanna fight a really good rest with you
he's just a high school wrestler on the
call right we get there and we're all
waiting to get in the hotel and this guy
comes in on this huge Harley and has a
big American flag and was like Jesus
Christ who was this and the guy goes
that's Johnny Curtis who the [ __ ]
Johnny Curtis he goes he's a wrestling
coach at George Mason Ford four-time
all-american
play wrestler on the national team I'm
like what
[ __ ] that's my opponent like that's him
damn so I was really upset
I just wanna let you know there's a
reason why him sorry I'm really upset
now this poor guy it's his hometown his
home college and I mean not only did I
knock him out with the left hook
but his knee blew out towards a co oh
and then yeah so good play they probably
paid for him I bet hometown hero did
that land or not cause that's gonna
promise to come today oh [ __ ]
boom knee blew out that's where I broke
my thumb now look what I do look I
almost blew my knee out here watch this
[Music]
lizard right here watch this blow my
knee out watch that was your [ __ ]
Chevelle since birth I was dude showing
off that [ __ ] bird boy oh that's
gonna happen you're white and jump a lot
I was so upset they tried they tried
hustling your boy they tried Sam back
[ __ ] bruh tried saying he's a really
nice guy was he yeah afterwards you're
friends now nice girl but then we didn't
realize my hand was that [ __ ] up we
knew we could see like bones protruding
out but it was like yeah well you'll be
all right my dad's like I've never been
to DC let's go see all the cool [ __ ] so
I'm like walking around all day
lightheaded my hands getting bigger it's
all that first what did you know I knew
I [ __ ] it up oh we didn't realize how
bad
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]